[Musica]
può essere umani sia programmatico la
salute mentale
il nostro cervello è un organo
programmato per proteggerci
abbiamo un sistema di protezione che ci
permette di elaborare lo stress tutte le
situazioni che possono avere un grande
impatto su di noi ed entusiamo la
possibilità di superare naturalmente lo
stress generato una situazione di
pericolo di disagio è una capacità di
elaborare in modo costruttivo tutte le
esperienze che possono avere un impatto
e che a volte ci fanno soffrire
a volte ci fanno arrabbiare cio ci
creano una sensazione di sconfitta
oppure di fallimento di frustrazione o
di d'onore il nostro cervello dotato di
un sistema in grado di elaborare tutte
queste esperienze
c'è il man mano che le viviamo vengono
codificate immagazzinate in memoria
ovviamente così riusciamo ad imparare e
ad avere un apprendimento che ci può
essere funzionale per altre situazioni
future quindi questo sistema è un modo
per elaborare le cose in modo
costruttivo e per crescere sempre da
situazioni anche molto dolorose
questo sistema in a volte viene
sopraffatto e quindi viene sopraffatto
dalla gravità dell'evento o si viene
sopraffatta e anche per esempio la
verità in cui vengono vissute con le
cose tutta la ricerca nel campo delle
neuroscienze cha fa ci fa capire come
c'è da vedere il bambino può integrare
solo alcun esperienza e altre fa molta
più fatica quindi assolutamente questo
queste esperienze sono molto pesanti non
sbaglio non riesce a quindi in queste
situazioni che questo sistema si blocca
e quindi è necessario dei dei metodi e
degli strumenti terapeutici che possono
riattivare queste capacità innata di
elaborare lo stress e il tram
in questo contesto al dr al ruolo di
andare a sbloccare questo questo sistema
in atto per portarlo a elaborare
completamente la situazione
le vedi r una terapia quindi che corda
la normalizzazione anche delle reazioni
emotive e lavora sul ricordo traumatico
e lo fa attraverso una stimolazione
bilaterale alternate è un movimento
oculare che sono simili a quello che
avviene durante sonno rem dove abbiamo
delle fasi di rapid eye movement e con
questo stesso sistema di movimenti
oculari nel paziente si concentra il suo
ricordo nella dell'evento traumatico si
riattiva questa capacità in hd
e quindi a quel punto il paziente vivrà
il ricordo distante si potrà pensare
all'esperienza in modo più sereno e
anche più libero e potrà andare avanti
poi nella vita superare questo e
vedranno da una prospettiva molto più
costruttiva quindi vediamo una terapia
che da trent'anni si focalizza sulle
elaborazioni dei ricordi traumatici che
è quello che rimane dopo un'esperienza
molto pesante è un ricordo quello che ci
continua a fare soffrire
quindi il mediano sito di un percorso
molto profondo di ricerca scientifica e
ha raccomandato dalle linee guida
internazionali utilizzato dai sistemi
sanitari nazionali moltissimi paesi
europei e anche livello internazionale
soprattutto dall'amministrazione
mondiale della salute è un trattamento
considerato e ridens bass che è
specifico anche per queste situazioni
remoto utilizzato in situazioni di
emergenza per esempio con vittime dei
terremoti di attacchi terroristici
vittime di violenza domestica mai che in
casi di lutto e soprattutto viene
utilizzato per una serie anche dei
disturbi e di difficoltà livello
psicologico o emotivo che sono legate a
suez e traumatiche il ruolo del croma
nella psicopatologia e qualcosa che è
morto ormai accertato i manuali
diagnostici segnale no e anche tutta la
letteratura internazionale quindi
importantissimo avere uno strumento che
ci aiuta in questo non senso può essere
applicato subito dopo l'evento
drammatico ma anche può essere applicato
dopo tanti anni
ovviamente prima interveniamo meglio è
questo viene molto utilizzato
nell'ambito della psicologia della
dell'emergenza e soprattutto in caso di
disastri naturali o disastri creati
dalla mano dell'uomo che colpiscono
magari tutta una comunità
un gruppo di famiglie quindi
importantissimo poter intervenire per
dare la possibilità questo a questo
sistema di ripartire da subito e fare
così prevenzione la saggezza popolare ci
ha consegnato un detto il tempo guarisce
tutte le ferite non è sempre così spesso
se ci sono situazioni di protezione
fattori favorevoli sicuramente ma molte
volte non ci sono tutta una serie di
fattori ci sono più che altro fattori di
rischio e quindi non non sempre il
nostro cervello ce la fa a normalizzare
l'evento traumatico ea riprendere la
vita come prima quindi è in questi casi
che abbiamo bisogno di un ad una terapia
specifica come lime dr
per per evitare e per prevenire
situazioni anche successiva come
disturbi post traumatici depressione
ansia e altre e altri gatti di saggi
quindi in questo metodo lavoro a livello
cognitivo a livello emotivo a livello
corporeo ma anche a livello
neurobiologico viene considerato una
terapia di tutto il cervello
importantissimo
questo perché quando noi viviamo una
situazione molto stressante traumatiche
viaggiamo solo a livello cognitivo ma
abbiamo tutta una serie di strutture
anche sottocorticali che rispondono a
preferiscono oa quello che sta
succedendo importante avere un metodo
che lavora a tutti i livelli in quella
science viene viene vissuta noi tendiamo
a pensare per esempio che le emozioni
sono programmabili a livello cognitivo
invece sono molto legate varie strutture
cerebrali che dicevamo che sono
sottocorticale
ed è importante poter lavorare le
metropia che lavora anche a quei livelli
quindi nel caso di drammatizzazioni
anche oltre e complesse e croniche e le
vedi nave viene utilizzato come parte di
tutta una terapia quindi questo
integrato in varie parti con altri
approcci terapeutici invece in emergenza
viene utilizzato nei protocolli
specifici che è secondo al punto le
linee guida internazionali sono molto
raccomandati ed efficace quindi sappiamo
moltissimo ad essere come noi il nostro
cervello reagisce a tutte queste
situazioni
questo percorso permette anche di
rafforzare le proprie risorse e le
capacità nell'esperienza man mano che
facciamo esperienze impariamo riusciamo
a gestire situazioni più complesse e
impariamo sempre di più a gestire
situazioni che possono verificarsi in un
percorso virtuoso di crescita costante
questa dinamica livello concettuale si
chiama crescita post traumatica un
percorso che ci permette di essere anche
delle persone più forti più competenti
in definitiva
sono i migliori dopo un'esperienza che
ci ha colpito che ci ha fatto soffrire
quindi questa è una grandissima capacità
che noi abbiamo nel processo di cura di
un tramonto cose ndr richiede lavorare
su tutti i frammenti dell'esperienza ed
è quello che ci permette di continuare a
crescere e imparare a usare
costruttivamente tutto quello che
abbiamo vissuto trattare tutti questi
disturbi ed eliminare la carica dolorosa
evitare che torni do e soprattutto
preparare la persona anche a poter
affrontare situazioni futuro che possano
assomigliare è qualcosa di molto molto
importante quindi il beneficio del
lavorare con ndr è duplice
oltre che alleviare gli effetti del
dramma da un punto di vista anche nella
di dare sollievo ma anche nella
prevenzione di ci permette di rafforzare
e di preparare la persona per il futuro
in un modo ecologico
quindi è importante avere uno strumento
di protezione sia per la sfera mentale
ed emotiva ma anche per la capacità di
adattamento delle persone gli effetti
sono immediatamente rilevabili
ripristinare questo efficacia che noi
abbiamo e il benessere e la salute
mentale nel minor tempo possibile
da una parte è importantissimo e
rafforzare i settori di protezione
dall'altra prepara sempre di più le
persone
quindi importante tenere presente che il
nostro cervello a un meccanismo in atto
di elaborazione dell'informazione che
funzionano sempre
a volte si blocca perché viene
sopraffatto dalla gravità delle spese
traumatiche
mdr riesce a riattivare questo sistema
aiutare a meglio a portare a termine
l'elaborazione che non era riuscito a
completare da solo lavorando in questo
modo
vediamo come la mente riesce a riparare
se stessa e soprattutto a a darci la
conferma che il nostro cervello
abbiamo una potenzialità senza limiti
per riprenderci e per andare oltre anche
alle sue grazie più dolorose